heading into spring 2015 you couldn't
help but feel a sense of uncertainty
surrounding Korean League of Legends
first starters former world champions SK
Telecom t1 had flopped in 2014 failing
to make Worlds
[Applause]
but the years biggest story line did not
center around the fact that faker and
company were proven to be mortal but
that most of Korea's talents including
all five members of 2014 world champion
Samsung whites had left Korea to compete
in the financially greener pastures of
China North America and Europe dubbed
the great Korean Exodus many wondered if
Korea could ever recover anyone good
here will be in China back here that
mind as he watched champions in Korea is
but a farm a farm for the other agents
during this period of change no one
would have predicted that a team would
come together and change the face of
Korea but it did and from that team two
players would form a bond that would
challenge dynasties good play from
gorilla lands the hook all too easily no
chains the corruption are gonna save you
from that one one was a washed-up former
superstar who had considered leaving the
scene for good the other was a rising
talent in need of a new home and yet
from the chaos of the great Korean
Exodus emerged one of the best bot lanes
of all time leaving their teams to
glories through their leadership
dedication and skill for prey it's a
tale of redemption for gorilla it's a
tale of potential becoming reality this
is the story of prey and gorilla we're
talking about ruler
holy goodbye originally from the Gangnam
neighborhood pray began playing league
of legends in university and as a
self-professed slacker often cut classes
to play as prey soloqueue rank improved
he eventually received offers from star
tail and nausea and am fire
but prey was wracked with doubt despite
the success in popularity of StarCraft
the negative stigma surrounding pro
gamers at the time kept prey from fully
embracing the idea of going pro
however the alternative staying in
school and dealing with guilt over his
poor grades convinced him that going pro
could be the right choice thankfully
that decision turned out better than
anyone could have hoped for they did get
him or did they well they got him a
couple times but he's still visible
there's a barrier brave trying to escape
as the flash dodges the undertow and
he'll actually make it out what an
incredible escape under the name troll
Kim praise Naja and debut launched him
into star status
almost immediately thanks in part to
superior mechanics positioning and a
deep champion pool the members of blue
kill all ready for play as he comes back
he's going for the Quadra gets it on the
spirit can they slow them down
can they get pray this pentakill it's
gonna take a long time to kill a carpet
another snowball great going for it
najin black sword would finish third in
their debut split and qualified for
world's 2012 after running the table in
the season 2 korea regional finals pray
and his team entered into Worlds 2012
bursting with confidence
however worlds did not pan out as prey
had imagined
they will be great admitted that black
sword were too cocky heading into their
match against TPA and thought themselves
to already be in the semi-finals it was
a valuable if brutal lesson to learn but
pray didn't let it drag him down nan
Jiang would go on to take second at the
MLG fall championship and win champions
winter to close out the domestic season
in a league of his own by the end of his
first year prey had already accomplished
so much a domestic title a top eight
finish at Worlds and the pride of
representing his country in a victorious
effort at All Stars it was an impressive
resume for just one year of competitive
play but the back half of 2013 would
prove to be the beginning of the end for
praised era of dominance
najin black sword has slipped from top
of the pack to a group stage exit in
championships summer 2013
[Music]
is it gonna be enough though
oh no members of najin sword dropping
left and right and CJ plays just ready
with the damage despite the poor results
in the spring and summer najin's winning
run in the winter 2012 season combined
with good results in the MLB League
Korea's second Pro division mint Nadja
and sword still finished the year atop
the Korean circuit and earned the top
seed heading into Worlds 2013
congratulations 2040 well-deserved win
right there they so they are not afraid
to return to the same champion pics even
after losing masterful play by the man
on your screen prey came to his left
they completely came up huge in the
bottom Lane there faker and SK Telecom
t1 K defeated none gen black sword in
dramatic fashion in the semi-finals to
advance to the finals where they went on
to win it all
[Applause]
the era of prey had come to an end his
talents surpassed by the likes of faker
still sitting goes just chuckwei brain
tried to flush it box goes down good
disengage it poohmandu tacking up that's
right
he's actually gonna fall but it will be
paid to forewarn in the end great roam
by faker up top although he would
reluctantly play for a few more months
in 2014
prey would go on to take a hiatus from
the competitive scene with his
confidence at an all-time low the man
once hailed as the best player in Korea
quietly left noggin as all this was
happening najin's other team white
shield had an awakening in fact as black
swords stock fell their sister team
would emerge to take their place as a
dark horse in Korea and among them was a
quiet humble player by the name of
gorilla Oh Zeb gets caught way off guard
gets bubbled there is a nice crescendo
but a tidal wave to follow up and
something gets locked out gorilla also
in trouble does not go down just yet but
space flashes for the poison not going
to take gorilla down previously living
in Indonesia and pulled from the ranks
of solo queue by nausea and white shield
gorillas entry into the ranks of korea's
elite was not met with fanfare and
praise in fact with names such as
poohmandu mada heart and mad life
competing against him gorillas play in
champions winter 2013 went largely
unnoticed
then with a shot at world's 2014 in the
balance
gorilla finally gained the attention
he's so fittingly deserved
he's stole baron and solar flare comes
now they may pay for it again the second
barons feeling rope from shield and
here's an equation a lot of damage get
goon gonna finally go down and it's
gonna be a day filled with an insane
comeback not only did his pocket Janna
reignite passion for the pic but najin's
incredible series of upsets against kt
rolster bullets kt rolster arrows and sk
telecom t1 k launched gorilla and white
shield into the spotlight
unlikely story for Najat shield to come
here and actually run the gauntlet
started at the bottom and climb their
way up to the very top and if they keep
playing the way they've been playing
they are a serious contender to win the
World Championships this year no longer
Korea's best kept secret gorilla entered
into Worlds 2014 ranked among the best
supports at the tournaments and
consequently the world sadly najin would
falter at the tournament losing a
perfect game to Alliance before getting
swept out of the tournament by oMG in
the quarterfinals
G hop done to take a down
despite the result he was a new star in
the region and with so many of Korea's
best players looking to China and the
West for big paydays he was looked at as
a linchpin around which the country's
future could hinge Gorillaz plans did
not involve the big organizations who
currently had a spot nor did it involve
the kind of money that drew his
colleagues to China in fact Gorillaz new
team would have to round up players that
were left off lck rosters and those that
elected to stay in Korea but who could
possibly fit the bill and still give
gorilla the chance to qualify for
Korea's top tier in 2015 after leaving
najin black sword prey waited and waited
he wanted to keep playing despite his
six-month absence but no teams called
with no offers and many rumors about
joining the army surfacing on social
media the ad Kerry had hit rock bottom
so when gorilla reached out to him
during his break to ask him to be a part
of a team that may make is a 2015
champions spring prey jumped at the
opportunity the GE Tigers went through
the qualifiers and made it to the top
tier of Korean league through the
veteran presence of the prey and gorilla
bot lane and a resurgent performance
from smeb in the top lane however their
first game as a duo in the lck would be
met with a lot of skepticism it's good
to see prey come back again has never
quite been able to reach the heights
that he used to get back on najin sword
but he's looking a bit better key to get
out was left to stand caught behind
enemy lines that essence is connects
there's the box plays to keep him inside
it olds to try to get away but being
slowed down too it's a rough area wasn't
quite close up there he tried so hard
with the hit what grade would you give
them for that game
be be not be plus not be minus just be I
think B is a good grade for the GE
Tigers for that game few mistakes but
they keep they finished it really strong
with some nice engages so B tear not
quite the grade you're looking for if
you're a team hoping to win a
championship prey and gorillas first
international event together saw them
lose at IEM against a struggling world
elite at the time this was considered
one of the biggest upsets in League of
Legends history last place LPL team
world elites toppling a GE Tigers team
that was sitting first in Korea and
that's it the best of three the first
time that we have seen the GE Tigers
lose a best-of series w e comes in here
with their new players no synergy no
experience and takes out an undefeated
Korean team this was considered
devastating for prey and gorillas being
unable to represent their region
properly on the world stage but despite
the disappointing international showing
prey gorilla and the rest of the then GE
Tigers still shattered expectations and
became a menace
domestically topping their first regular
season in Korea and making the finals
Tigers versus sk telecom here in the
champions spring grand finals from there
it was the start of an epic Carine
rivalry trying to talk about the Tigers
is to talk about their foil SK Telecom
t1 the best team in league of legends
history
the Tigers would constantly come up
short against the Korean powerhouse when
it really mattered GE Tigers showing
once again how dangerous they can be
from behind but they're squirming just
not up to the task of getting those
early leads up against SKT they were
always one step behind as SKT would
cruise to championships in 2015 lck
spring 2015 l ck summer and 2016 lck
spring just like that
SK Telecom shows you who is the best
team fighting team off this planet
despite that prey and gorilla delivered
some of the most interesting moments and
innovative strategies during the season
but yeah pilot does go down double kill
for a GBM it's all on him he needs to do
damage but no triple kill for brave prey
and gorilla kept marching on with subtle
tweaks to their roster and play style
adding peanut in the jungle gave them
more firepower and freedom for the bot
lane duo to really make their mark
cavener goes down with two members out
of commission death timers are so short
whoa peanut jungle versus mid laner no
problem prey and gorilla one lck summer
with the Rox Tigers finally standing
tall as the best team in Korea and
generating a ton of hype for their
worlds run this group of players that
have either retired or been rejected by
she comes in no big sponsor no big team
house it's
necessary because they are going to lck
summer and they are going to get a
spotted world's again they did this
however without conquering their demons
historically SKT have always found the
edge that's definitely true that's been
three matchups between these two teams
worlds however would be the true test
for this new age Korean all-star lineup
led by the confidence that the lck
victory brought the tigers looked like
favourites to most you're asking who I'm
predicting for this game and it's gonna
be the Rox Tigers I think the Rox Tigers
seems to like the Rox Tigers too though
they didn't face SKT to win the lck and
their record against them in big matches
was lacking it was poised to be their
chance to break apart the dynasty
everyone was expecting this to be the
final this is the final last year but
they're drawn in the semi-finals and
they have to take it right now even if
this is the hardest matchup you were
going to have to go through SKT are
rocks anyway if you want the title and
these teams are ready
when your gorilla it's time to play
support misfortune whooping is just
going to be too much damage to been
killed and they even got the pickoff on
bank rocks doesn't actually have to stop
pushing right now they can delay the
recalls
looking to make it 2-1 in the series
rocks going for the play another coaster
for peanut there's the Nexus Becky subs
back and he saves SKT now we're going to
get five
despite their ingenuity it was not
enough following Worlds 2016 all five
members of Rox Tigers would leave and go
their own way with the exception of prey
and gorilla who stayed together and
joined long zoo I really like this
roster when I heard about the genesis
when I see it it makes sense this is a
five-man roster where there isn't too
many carries where there is power and
there's no more power than that bot lane
because prey and gorillas are fantastic
they know each other inside and out and
okay
the Rox Tigers splintered but one of the
key components this bot Lane they can be
aggressive that could be defensive that
are wonderful together stay together and
that makes me at least very high when
the team faltered in the 2017 spring
season long zoo reset the roster long
zoo then went on to finish first in the
summer split and finally take down SKT
in the summer finals
[Applause]
the lck it's long too gamy
this wins solidified their status as the
top Korean team on their way to Worlds
2017 coming in as the number one seed
from Korea for the second year in a row
prey and gorilla had high expectations
especially with a victory over SKT now
under their belts they were the only
team to six-oh their group in the group
stage this year but were defeated by
another Korean team at quarterfinals
there is nothing left to stop Samsung
Galaxy as they take down their first
opponent they are the first of the
semifinals and who can't really stop
this team
pray and gorillas had been through hell
and back collectively they've
experienced brutal defeats perfect games
international disappointment potential
retirement and subsequently have climbed
to the highest tiers despite the
failures this is the long-term we wanted
to see in this series in the grand
scheme of things their trials and
tribulations put them among the best bot
laners in the entire world the final
thing that they're still missing is that
one world championship that one chance
to cement themselves as true legends in
the game thanks for watching if you want
more great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]